[музика]
прийшли окупанти до нас в Україну форма
новенького я не машини це чіпай
поплаваемся їх інвентарним
аерокар
[музика]
Олександр Вітаю вітаю
доброго дня не говорю та ніхто вже
зараз не говорити біржові стратегії
сьогодні немає взагалі атавізму чи ви
сподіваєтеся професія залишитися в крим
випадку працюватиму дідом морозом як
25 років тому
прийшла його окупанти до нас в Україну
форма новенького їй не машини це чіпай
поплавок за їх інвентарним
аерокар
[музика]
але підскок російський світ прийшов
ось багато зустрічаючи російський світ
скажіть україна
[оплески]
Візьміть насіння покладіть сир і це шлях
соняшники росли готовими пляжі
[музика]
танки йдуть заднім ходом
російські танки списувалися купою
шаблон тобі 40 бат і довбання рахунки
чіпаючих бери все на лару
аерокар
[музика]
байрак
їх докази всяке засвоєння рис на ракети
під уже не машини за лізні у нас
археолога та komandor
байрактор
[музика]
а
волосся
[музика]
наші тягнуть бтр додому до двору
нахуй би metal scene буде залишки
металобрухтом та шкода звичайно за таку
техніку запустити у сільське господарство
[ __ ] можна було звичайно
маніпулятором на робити саме млинець 4
злі москаля купалися від і при а тут
Микола з калашом і ихласе рости при мозок
алекса лазаєш ви закінчите худоби
вивернувши абрис і їх втратила
2-го москаля підбив і в лісі втікає
шиве кмин ми хочу стати і успішних за
втратиш 1
поверхні вся і нажити підлоги утубі жар
а зверху tell if сюжет безшумний
байрактор
і
поки мій
а й коротше
ось паракорд
москаль
робітники
а
мені потрібно щось сказати
російські боями корабель іди нахуй
елади широко хворіє не про гру дуже
стан про що вам
околиці
дуже
переходити до сцени гори чорне море
[оплески]
я.
100 вночі вам
москалів
патчі
[музика]
косатки та ебуча блювати
це жахливий поляки ось турки молодців ж
бляти допоможи блювати спасибі їм ця робота
варненській би хто рублів до
[музика]
Наприкінці у нас барани для
відновлення великої країни найкраще
пастух бару няче хоторн
байрактор
[музика]
почитайте уважно тут написано це
в Росії
слава україні героям слава путін [ __ ]
вирішать написано за смерть фондового ринку
сьогодні я п'ю газовану воду
дорогий фондовий ринок був нам близький
був цікавий спокій зі світом дорогою
товариш
це в Росії на трасі Санкт-Петербург
москва це на державний за cd
як таке може бути скажіть у нас немає
жодної втрати дано одного пораненого
людини
немає жодного подряпин done
[музика]
але
[оплески]